pardon larcat parce que c'est une bonne
période
musicalement et surtout sa marque mes
débuts à paris comment soutenir leurs
cartes
parce que il n'y a pas que des mauvaises
choses qui sont issus de la télé-réalité
et à beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs qui
s'en sont inspirés et puis ça fait
tellement nos enfants parce que parce
qu'on n'a pas envie d'en parler alors à
sera pas l'interview d'arca parce que ça
ça c'est un vrai beau on est capable on
l'a prouvé aujourd'hui nous européens et
même les espagnols grâce à la case de
départ l on peut rivaliser avec les
américains et faire des séries qui sont
de top niveau
kelly très bien parce qu'entre les connu
la première fois dans le dit dans son
clip
de bella et ensuite j'ai eu la chance de
la voir au vip room aux platines du vip
room en duo avec une autre jeune fille
et
vraiment très toujours très cool avec
note sera parce que ces interminables
c'est un tunnel et que je suis un enfant
du sud et que je n'aime que l'été d'arca
c'est bien le bg c'est une grande équipe
de football a une grande équipe de
football en france avec des grands
joueurs un stade de folie la qualité tu
as plus grands dj français carrière
exceptionnelle et surtout un producteur
hors du commun